on se retrouve pour nadal ou portrait
aujourd'hui benno besson pour sa mise en
scène de la flûte enchantée à l'opéra
garnier bonsoir bonsoir alors benno
besson on a beaucoup parlé de vous ici
philippe tesson et jacques nerson nous
ont parlé incessamment de vous d'abord à
l'occasion du roi servent de carlo gozzi
cause et mis en scène à chaillot en 2000
et puis évidemment en 2001 le cercle de
craie caucasien énorme succès deux
molières on voit qu'il a été beaucoup
question de vous je sais très impatients
de vous connaître vous êtes ici
aujourd'hui donc pour la flûte enchantée
de mozart au palais garnier alors le 6 9
11 14 18 21 24 27 juin plus de 6 juillet
c'est à 19h30 et ça dure trois heures au
palais garnier voilà alors la musique
évidemment c'est mozart le livre et
c'est emmanuel schikaneder la direction
musicale armin jordan décors et costumes
jean marc stehlé et mise en scène de
vous benno besson alors si vous deviez
résumer la flûte enchantée vous diriez
quoi jeu direct un compte c'est un monde
qui pète de
delamain traitance d'une
reine de la nuit par un par un
patriarche qui s'appelle sarastro
d'une histoire d'amour qui se termine
vaguement bien mais
vraiment très bas comme en bien d'autres
part que c'est
que c'est un que c'est surtout un opéra
que que mozart avait créé avec
schikaneder dans un théâtre de boulevard
donc dans la banlieue de biens ne vienne
voilà ce qui me paraît important
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble
magnéto
[Musique]
la flûte
touche pas à la cheville
aulas
[Musique]
seul
amis
[Musique]
voilà donc la flûte enchantée de mozart
a été créée en 1791 à vienne sous la
direction de mozart lui même et chicanes
et d'heures jouer le rôle de papageno et
vos choix sont directement inspirés de
cette première version cire que vous
vous refusez le parti-pris
philosophique le refus aussi du côté
grande messe et vous choisissez le conte
merveilleux l'humour la première chose
qu'il faut que je dis c'est que vraiment
l'opéra j je ne me sens pas du tout à
l'aise à l'opéra la seule chose que vous
ayez fait ici c'est un pur hasard que
galles mais demandez à genève parce
qu'il aimait bien les spectacles que je
faisais mais demander de faire la paix
quelque chose à
genève quand il avait le grand tokyo et
là j'ai proposé la flûte parce que
c'était quelque chose qui me paraissait
très proche du théâtre ouais voilà un
parti-pris pas du tout grand'messe
pourquoi en fait pas du tout on voit
bien d'ailleurs dans l'extrait convient
de voir pourquoi aussi peu de d'opéra
justement c'est parce que le chef
d'orchestre a beaucoup de pouvoirs à
l'opéra et c'est vous en laisse un peu
moins ben oui aussi mais aussi surtout
oui oui c'est à dire que bach à l'opéra
la
musique et est là prêt qui dit tout oui
qui dit tout ce qu'on doit dire un au
théâtre ce qui est agréable c'est qu'on
écrit la musique oui vous comprenez en
entreprise en mettant ses compétences et
non on a quelques on écrit un peu de
musique est loin que c'est c'est plus
amusant
alors benno besson vous êtes suisse vous
êtes né à yverdon en 1922 d'ailleurs
là-bas le théâtre porte votre nom
désormais vos parents étaient
instituteurs et y rêver que vous
deveniez pasteur pasteur protestant mais
déjà tout petit vous étiez fasciné par
bach voir les spectacles des fanfares
par les cirques enfin par toute la tuta
dimension théâtrale de la vie dévote
plus jeune âge mais c'est à dire que non
j'ai essayé de comprendre pourquoi
j'avais toujours dit que j'allais faire
que je voulais faire du théâtre et je me
suis rendu compte que vous que dans mon
petit village là la fanfare avait
organisé un
une soirée et il joue et il jouait un
une sorte de western enfin y avait il y
avait des y avait des blancs qui
délivrait
un des leurs prix par les indiens et ils
tiraient des coups de fusil voilà je me
souviens que on se cachait sous les
bandes en énonçant avait fait grande
impression je souhaiterais bien de ce
jour là et
nombreuses occasions je me souvenais me
suis souvenu de ce soir là et c'est la
seule fois où j'ai vu du théâtre là où
j'étais n'y avait pas alors très jeune
vous êtes par exemple à l'âge de 7 ans
vous monter une pièce sur les malheurs
de votre mère à chef dentiste un nom
mais ça c'est inouï mais c'était un non
je suis un peu de marionnettes oui parce
que j'avais dit que je suis dit allons y
avec pris ça au sérieux et m'a donné des
marionnettes
qu'une pièce humain qui était très
mauvaise passe qu'il n'y avait rien à
jouer je m'étais complètement perdu dans
le lait sont que qu'on faisait en trash
en enlevant craché alors vous dites je
ne comprends le monde qu'en essayant je
ne comprends le monde qu'en essayant de
le mettre en scène sinon je suis nul non
ce qui me semble quand on fait du
théâtre on fait de l'art en général
c'est que on joue
on joue avec la réalité on est on met la
réalité en jeu et ses sacs et
c'est en ce sens que ça un rapport avec
l'art de vivre parce qu'on essaye donc
comme les comme les bébés apprennent à
vivre en jouant on appelle ça jouer sur
les anglais bon bah il y jouer qu'ils
apprennent à vivre en jouant ils
apprennent le monde cette façon
d'appréhender le monde alors si on
arrive à garder un tout petit peu de
l'urgence que prouvent les bébés et de
leurs
et de la concentration qu'ils y mettent
et de la naïveté qu'ils y mettent sans
aucunement aucun préjugé
ça on peut en arrive encore même adulte
à faire un petit peu quelque chose qui
ressemble à du jeu en la date importante
de votre vie ces 42 vous êtes étudiant à
l'université de zurich et vous découvrez
mère courage de brecht eu
ensuite lors d'un voyage à lyon fait la
connaissance de jean marie serreau et de
geneviève ses rôles et les parents de
coline serreau qui deviendra votre votre
épouse il est connu à l'âge de deux ans
mais votre rencontre disons plus réel ce
sera fin de trois ans plus tard donc à
lyon vous rencontrer les héros et vous
devenez tous les trois des plus grands
et pratiquement les seuls fans de brecht
à cette époque
c'est à dire qu'en france on ne parlait
pas beaucoup de bruit à l'époque et les
mois j'avais vu j'avais vu brest à
zurich les anti fasciste allemands et
autrichiens qui était réfugié à zurich
ont fait un théâtre extraordinaire
pendant la guerre et longs qu'ils ont
créé mère-courage ces deux choix n'est
galilée a assuré que j'ai vu tout ça et
quand je quand j'étais j'étais invité à
la suite de théâtre d'amateurs que
j'avais fait en suisse française j'étais
invité à lyon où il y avait un espèce
d'instituts et qui zappe les jeunes
france et
qui devait durer six mois j'y suis resté
un mois et demi parce que il a été fermé
pour faits de résistance donc on nous a
refoulé sur l'a6 non et c'est là que
j'ai connu jean marie serreau et j'ai
évidemment je lui parlais beaucoup de
break 1 et après après guerre il m'a
demandé de lui ramener quelque chose et
je vais ramener une pièce de moins est
ce qu'il a fait dans ses spectacles
en allemagne en allemagne et zone
occupée
occupé à nous alors quand vous montez
quand vous montez brecht et avec ce
héros enfin au départ vous fait
assassiner par elsa triolet dans les
lettres françaises pensent qu'à l'époque
les communistes s'intéressait pas du
tout à brecht contrairement à plus tard
où ils sont on pourrait dire de façon
trop intéressé nos départs finalement
c'était pas il n'est pas cet engouement
qui a eu par la suite pour brest oui je
ne sais pas trop pourquoi je sais
seulement que ont joué en allemand à la
commune champs elysées en venant
d'allemagne donc dans une occupation où
on avait joué en allemand et enfin
voulons jouer un molière en français et
le break finalement moi je jouais joué
le guide dans la halle exceptionnel et
je sais qu'à la pause on avait joué
d'abord l'exception à la règle en
allemand et avons crié qu'il est mais
qui pouvait pas entendre cette langue
dray voilà je pense qu'il y avait une
version nationale lui as a way we et
comme les communistes en rapport direct
avec moscou cet été
alalalala l'ère des hausses étaient
alors rencontré brecht a à zurich en 48
et en 49 ils vous demandent de venir le
rejoindre à à berlin est où il venait de
créer le berliner ensemble dont vous
êtes engagés au départ comme comédien et
comme assistant metteur en scène dans la
troupe de la troupe de brèches quoi
j'ai joué ouais si bien sûr
extraordinaire vous été un témoin
privilégié de 2,2 de la troupe y virent
une extraordinaire bref c'est que enfin
tout le monde sait que nous ça c'est
peut-être trop peu que les années 20 en
allemagne ont été
ont été le fait d'une explosion
culturelle extraordinaire
absolument extraordinaire en europe il
n'y a rien eu de pareilles et brecht à
communiquer un peu de ça à berlin
rencontré humains communiquer un peu de
cette époque de la vie d'avant guerre
finalement qui survivaient grâce à lui
c'était quel genre d'homme brecht
comment dire ça s'il était bien ouais
non ces mystérieux non mais oui
non mais enfin il était il était surtout
généreux il était très généreux et il
écouter les gens il est il écouter les
gens elle les entendais et ils étaient
ils n'étaient pas orgueilleux
savez c'était des qualités tout de même
appréciable alors vous retrouver là-bas
donc évidemment laird et à l'époque où
tout début ça représentait un espoir la
naissance de la rda surtout pour le
jeune trotsky ce que vous étiez il y
avait cette idée on pouvait encore
construire le socialisme et puis la rda
au départ à était pas ce qu'elle est
devenue par la suite c'est à dire que
les premiers présidents de rda était
encore assez c'est honnête assez près du
peuple n'ont
été les lepic et groote vol était très
intéressé à l'art il avait un plus
profond respect pour pour des gens pour
des gens comme ces gars comme anna
seghers comme brest et les autres
et donc ça c'était était à g d'auto par
mois en tant que trop ce qui n'était pas
exactement l'endroit que j'aurai choisi
oui mais ce n'est pas la faire mais la
sphère ski ça m'intéressait de voir ce
qui ce qui pouvait se faire sous le mot
socialisme voilà alors faut dire aussi
effectivement que les artistes en
allemagne de l'est étaient davantage
reconnus et aider qu'ailleurs vous vous
en servir un peu mieux vous achetez
votre première radio et puis
contrairement à l'époque de jean marie
serreau vous n'êtes plus obligé de
bouffer des pommes de terre à tous à
tous les repas quoi donc c'est une vie
un peu plus agréable pour les artistes
c'est à dire oui parce que je n'étais
pas habitué à être payés chaque mois oui
puis c'est tout c'est tout alors là
j'étais payé chaque mois s'était pas
beaucoup
mais même avec ce qu'on gagne et la
moins pour moi c'était énorme alors au
début vous pensiez rester deux ans à
berlin est et puis revenir en france
travailler avec jean marie serreau en
fait j'étais resté neuf ans là bas avec
avec brèche et vous partez parce que
vous êtes mis à l'écart par hélène weigl
qu'elle était là une des fondatrices du
berliner qui était la gardienne du
brecht is mais vous vous élevez un petit
peu contre le brésil parce que vous
dites que brecht lui-même n'était pas
brecht east de toute façon c'est à dire
que brest n'a jamais voulu signer une
mise en scène que je faisais de ce qui
me disait juste parce que moi je lui
disais même quand même voit beaucoup
aidé la wii bassiste et où j'aurais bien
voulu qu'ils signent avec moi parce
qu'il avait signé avec d'autres inculpés
retirer s'il est bon alors un coin ne
voulait pas et j'ai demandé pourquoi il
m'a dit il m'a dit qu'il me dit moi je
vous ai aidé à faire ce que vous aviez
envie de faire moi je l'aurais fait tout
autrement au nez mais ça c'est une
preuve de sa générosité a sermonné pas
dogmatique du tout il m'a laissé faire
et il m'a aidé à faire ce que j'avais
envie de faire connaissance et et et
donc c'est la façon dont on travaille et
quand on travaillait à une adaptation
parce que c'était pareil partager les
droits tout ça en fait oui oui bien sûr
non humains il ya un livre abominable de
fouet
et on disait qu'il était nazi
homosexuels qui piquent alizés de tout
le monde service client 95 venir c'est
détestable je connais
bien alors
évidemment le lit des socialistes a
connu bien des avatars depuis les débuts
de la rda est souvent dans vos
déclarations et notamment quand vous
parlez du cercle vous dit que finalement
la lutte des classes à laquelle
vous croyez à l'époque à laquelle brecht
croyez aussi est devenue la lutte des
sexes et vous opposez dans le monde
c'est une idée intéressante vous opposez
dans le monde la tendance viril et la
tendance féminine c'est à dire que c'est
à dire que c'est pas qu'elle l'a
remplacé parce que la lutte des classes
et
exister je n'ai pas aimé la lutte des
sexes et s'est vu un peu moins dix
ans tandis qu on est passé du patriarcat
féodal au patriarcat marchand 89
il ya eu un petit un petit temps de
patriarcat
pour les terriens pour l'état rien qui
était ma pas extrêmement brillant non
plus gros bonnets et maintenant on
continue le pater camera vivement le
patriarcat marchand bon il a évidemment
que les patriarches ont des avantages
ils ont inventé toutes sortes de choses
et bien mais mais il est il est évident
que les la guerre des sexes qui dure
depuis très très longtemps depuis depuis
3000 ans avant avant jésus-christ en
fait depuis les grecs depuis
visite qu'avait tendance viril qui sont
dangereuses pour les humains et pour la
nature d'une certaine façon c'est à dire
que le
le geste est nette ouais vous venez un
ce geste là et
cette volonté de dons de dompter la
nature
de la soumettre
de la soumettre est absolument signé in
i latéral parce que tout de même il faut
bien se dire que nous sommes la nature
aussi version donc et quand on se met à
soumettre qui que ce soit d'entre nous
c'est pas bon c'est nous mêmes qu'on
souhaitait voilà vous dites la lutte des
classes finalement n'est peut-être plus
aussi utile dans un monde où 80% de la
population n'est pas nécessaire à
l'exploitation capitaliste à dire
qu'aujourd'hui à tellement de gens qui
sont sur le bas côté de la route que
finalement le système de lutte des
classes fonctionne puisque le capitaine
n'a plus besoin de les exploiter peau
pour exister montagne et c'est pas moi
qui le dis oui c'est
hier une conférence des grands pontes de
la finance et de l'industrie et de la
politique interview au canada et
là où par exemple je crois que c'était
chinsky enfin qu'il disait qu'il y avait
80 % de personnes de personnes inutiles
pour la poursuite du capitalisme donc ça
c'est beaucoup donc il fallait savoir ce
qu'on veut c'est
une chose qui n'a pas changé finalement
je dirais depuis l'époque de la rda
depuis l'époque dès débuts de la rda
quand vous travaillez avec bertold
brecht c'est que finalement le fossé
entre ça c'est une idée qui
malheureusement un fait qui ne s'est
malheureusement pas démenti de fossé
entre les pauvres et les riches ne cesse
de s'élargir mais inexorablement
le train oui le train est tout de même
il faudrait faudrait voir ce que ça
donnait enfin tous les problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui à la plupart des gros points
même confronté de ces derniers temps
d'ailleurs viennent beaucoup d'une
organisation du monde qui amène qui
amène sa dernière question benno besson
est ce que vous croyez qu'au delà de la
chute du mur et je dirais aujourd'hui
des accords poutine bush est ce que vous
croyez que l'idée communiste j'ai pas
dis stalinienne l'idée communiste peut
revenir dans le monde une chose c'est
que par exemple j'ai toujours été
extrêmement fasciné par une phrase de
marx sais pas si j'ai déjà bien la
traduire mais qui dit que l'émancipation
des hommes viendraient au moment oui
pourrait
concevoir et organiser leurs forces
propres comme étant des forces sociales
sonné s'est hissé dans sa critique des
droits de l'homme et de la donc de dix
ans que 89 avait séparé l'homme
individuels égoïstes du citoyen et
social abstrait donc l'homme concret et
le citoyen abstrait et il pensait que
l'émancipation humaine ce benêt
viendrait gravel ont figuré en travail
oit concevoir et organiser ses forces
propres des gens comme étant des forces
sociales
merci benno besson très heureux de vous
avoir rencontré bravo on a beaucoup
parlé de vous ici fut très sûrs d'eux a
reconnu et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu